la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves d'usage madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je voulais
vous dire que c'est avec émotion une
émotion vive que nous avons appris la
mort dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche à
crépole dans la drrome d'un adolescent
de 16 ans Thomas décédé des suites d'un
coup de couteau reçu alors qu'il
participait à un bal pouris
simplement nous associons par la pensée
à la marche organisée cet après-midi à
roman sur iser pour lui rendre hommage
au nom du Sénat j'assure de notre
profonde sympathie sa famille ses
proches les élus municipaux de crépul
que je sais particulièrement atteint et
l'ensemble des victimes blessées cette
nuit-là dans des circonstances qu'il
appartiendra à la justice de déterminé
chers collègues nous sommes très heureux
d'accueillir dans notre tribune dans le
cadre de la Semaine Européenne de
l'emploi pour les personnes handicapées
des personnes en situation de handicap
il s'agit de Andréa de berenis d'Élodie
de Kevin de Maxime et de Samuel qui vont
pouvoir découvrir le fonctionnement de
notre
institution le Sénat participe chaque
année à cette initiative et au cours
notamment de la journée de demain bon
nombre de nos collègues constitueront
des duos avec des personnes en situation
de handicap pour les associer à leur
activité le Sénat est mobilisé nous en
avons parlé au dernier bureau et
Monsieur ououias il sera sensible le
Sénat est pleinement mobilisé pour
l'inclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap dans le monde du travail
notamment travers de ces journées
d'échange qui constitu un moment
privilégié pour changer de regard et
ensemble dépasser nos préjugés alors au
nom du Sénat tout entier je voulais
souhaiter à ces jeunes la plus cordiale
bienvenue dans notre
émission madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je donne immédiatement la parole à notre
collègue Bernard bu pour le le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrate progressiste
et
indépendant
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question à laquelle
j'associe mes collègues dromois
Marie-Pierre Monier et Gilbert boucher
s'adressent à madame la Première
ministre alors que notre assemblée vient
de lui rendre hommage une marche blanche
se déroule actuellement dans la Drome à
roman suriser en souvenir de Thomas âgé
de 16 ans mortellement poignardé à
crépul dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
nos pensées vont à sa famille ses amis
son lycée ses camarades de club de
à toutes les personnes blessées ainsi
qu'à l'ensemble des habitants de ce
village meurtris par cette tragédie
samedi soir alors que le traditionnel
bal d'hiver été organisé par le comité
des fêtes de cette commune de 500
habitants la convivialité a été stoppée
par l'atrocité selon le procureur de la
République au cours de ces violences
plus d'une quinzaine de personnes ont
été blessées madame la Première ministre
face à une telle violence gratuite et
débridé nous partégeons la sidération et
la peine des habitants de notre
département pour nous androme c'est tout
sauf un fait divers l'émotion nous
tenaille à cette douleur s'ajoute
d'inévitables questions pourquoi
pourquoi eux pourquoi à crépul pourquoi
Thomas une enquête est en cours et elle
devrait je l'espère apporter des
réponses je salue la réactivité des
forces de l'ordre qui ont procédé hier à
l'interpellation de neuf individus pas
de conclusions active laissons la
justice travailler cela étant vu la
nature de ces actes criminels qui
semblent prémédités et réalisés en B
organiser nous devons collectivement
nous interroger afin de tout faire pour
éviter que de tels drames ne se
reproduisent dans notre République
madame la Première ministre en cette
semaine de congrès des maires où de
nombreux élus nous écoutent comment
pouvons-nous davantage accompagner et
rassurer nos commune surtout en
territoire rural pour que les événements
indispensables à la vie de nos villages
à l'image du bal de crépole puissent
perdurer dans la
sérénité pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bernard buit vous l'avez
rappeler monsieur le sénateur dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche à crépool dans
votre département de la Drome Thomas un
jeune de 16 ans a été tué à la sortie
d'une fête au cœur même de son village
avant toute chose je veux à mon tour
dire toute ma solidarité à sa famille à
ses proches à tous les habitants de
crépool je veux adresser mes pensées aux
personnes blessées certaines sont encore
dans un état grave c'est un drame qui
touche tout un village nous sommes au
côté de la mre de crépool Madame Martine
lagu monsieur le sénateur ces violences
sont graves elles sont inacceptables une
enquête judiciaire a immédiatement été
ouverte 70 auditions ont d'ors déjà été
mené les enquêteurs travaillent
d'arrachepied pour faire toute la
lumière sur ce drame d'ors et déjà donc
neuf personnes ont été interpellées
l'enquête permettra de déterminer les
responsabilités de chacun j'ai confiance
dans nos forces de l'ordre et dans notre
justice toute la vérité sera faite sur
ce crime les auteurs et leurs complices
devront répondre de leurs actes
aujourd'hui l'heure est à l'enquête et
au recueillement comme vous je le sais
Monsieur le Sénateur je suis convaincu
que ce moment appelle à la retenue et à
la dcence utiliseer ce drame pour jouer
sur les peurs c'est manquer de dignité
et de respect pour les
victimes monsieur le sénateur vous le
dites ce drame soulève des questions
plus larges mon gouvernement est bien
conscient des évolutions de la
délinquence en particulier dans nos
territoires ruraux c'est la raison pour
laquelle conformément aux engagements du
Président de la République et en
application de la loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur porté par le ministre Gérald
armanin nous créons 239 nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie dont deux dans
votre département de la Drome 239
nouvelles brigades ce sont plus de 2000
gendarmes supplémentaires dans nos
territoires ruraux monsieur le sénateur
je veux vraiment vous en assurer la
présence des forces de l'ordre partout
sur le territoire notamment dans la
ruralité c'est une priorité pour mon
gouvernement je vous remercie merci
madame la Première ministre la parole
est à notre collègue Marie-Claude
l'ermite pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et
territoire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues chacun sait
la gravité de la situation dans le Nord
mais surtout dans le Pas de calis je
tiens d'abord à exprimer ma profonde
solidarité envers les habitants les
professionnels les agriculteurs mais
aussi envers les élus les bénévoles et
tous les services mobilisés des communes
durement touchés par les inondations
certaines d'entre elles sont déjà
reconnues en état de catastrophe
naturelle inévitablement beaucoup
d'autres suivront après le temps de la
sidération viendra le temps des bilans
et projections que pensez du
fonctionnement et des moyens alloués à
l'institution des wateringes des
sections de l'état des matériel de
pompage de la consommation électrique
des ves à réparer d'un éventuel curage
de laa et des canaux non navigués et
complètement
envasé quelle a été l'efficacité des
bassins de rétention de cru les
pratiques culturales permettent-elles
toujours la percolation des terrain les
acteurs de terrain sont nombreux doivent
se réunir afin d'évaluer les pistes
permettant une meilleure régulation des
cru c'est un impératif une chose est
sûre l'État devra faire un effort
financier conséquent car les
collectivités ne peuvent plus tout
supporter suite aux inondations de
décembre 2021 mon prédécesseur
Jean-Pierre de col formulé des
propositions faciliter et développer le
draguage et le curage des canaux avec
une logique de réemploi des sédiments
utiliser les canaux non navigués comme
des bassins de rétention et de
régulation je partage ses propositions
monsieur le ministre entendez-vous
engager rapidement ces travaux de
réflexion associant tous les acteurs de
terrain afin que nos territoires
puissent s'organiser et anticiper les
prochaines crues dont tout à chacun
redoute le retour des moyens conséquents
seront-ils mis à
disposition j'espère comme la météo
aujourd'hui que votre réponse sera une
bel éclairci pour les territoires
sinistrés je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la transition
écologique la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Christophe
Béchu monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'Hermite je commence tout
comme vous par m'associer aux forces de
l'ordre aux bénévoles aux équipe
municipale au sens très large qui encore
aujourd'hui malheureusement ne conjugue
pas ces inondations au passé maisue de
lutter contre une partie de ces
stigmates y compris après les épisodes
de pluie de ce début de semaine vous
vous tournez tout de suite vers l'après
vers le retour d'expérience que nous
allons avoir besoin collectivement de
bâtir il a commencé doucement premièree
visite avec Gérald daranin première
rencontre avec les élus le président de
la République qui s'est rendu sur place
le 14 novembre avec Olivia Grégoire Marc
fenau l'activation du dispositif des
calamités agricoles et la première
ministre il y a quelques jours qui était
au côté des sinistrés j'aurai l'occasion
dans les prochaines semaine de retourner
au contact des élus sans attendre j'ai
transmis au Conseil d'État un projet de
décret pour faciliter le curage pas
seulement dans le Pas de Calais vous
vous doutez bien que si on l'a débloqué
en quelques jours c'est parce que
c'était déjà un texte sur lequel nous
étions en train de travailler depuis
plusieurs semaines en mesurant bien qu'à
un moment il faut qu'on soit capable de
regarder ce qui dans la préservation de
l'environnement doit aller avec la
préservation d'un autre principe de
précaution celui-là très clair et qui
fait que curé est une nécessité pour
lutter contre les inondations il y a
beaucoup de leçons à tirer de la même
manière que les inondation de 2002 nous
ont permis d'améliorer les dispositifs
de prévention et d'alerte nous aurons à
nous interroger sur les régén par le
fonctionnement des wateringues y compris
sur ce territoire sur le fonctionnement
des pompes sur la manière dont au-delà
du curage la taille des organisations
des syndicats se font et même à regarder
les choses au niveau international
puisque le président de la République a
souhaité que nous puissions comparer les
systèmes de lutte en Belgique en
Hollande avec ce qui se passe en France
en confiant au maire de Saint-Omer une
mission qui permette justement d'aller
comparer ce type de politique nous avons
été au rendez-vous de l'alerte nous
avons été au rendez-vous des
catastrophes naturel nous serons
rendez-vous des retours d'expérience
madame la
sénatrice la parole est à notre collègue
Jean ivrou pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la
parole merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues il y a 10 ans le
Parlement a adopté la loi de
modernisation de l'action publique
territoriale et d'affirmation des
métropoles dite loi maptam parmi les
dispositions de cette loi figure la
création d'une ce nouvelle gmapi pour
assurer le financement de cette mission
la loi mapin prévoyait la possibilité de
lever une taxe optionnelle dans la
limite de 40 € par habitant pour
protéger les territoires les plus
vulnérables en disant mes chers
collègues que s'est-il passé disons-nous
disons-nous disposons-nous des moyens
nécessaires pour nous protéger contre
les inondations la réponse est non en
disant mes chers collègues le
dérèglement climatique est allé plus
vite que nos décisions politiques en
disant les intercommunalités exposé au
ris que n'ont pas eu les moyens pour
mener les investissements nécessaires
dans mon département mais comme tant
d'autres la donnée est simple peu
d'habitats beaucoup de cours d'eau à
protéger faute de moyens les communautés
de communes concernées n'arrivent même
pas à financer les études préliminaires
les conséquences nous les connaissons
une P de dameoclaè c'est au final un
coût financier humain qui alourdira nos
charges d'assurance obérera nos
capacités budgétaires fragilisera les
plus fragiles détruira nos paysages
monsieur le ministre cela fait quelques
années que les collectivités alertent
mais que cela ne déclenche pas la
réflexion opérationnelle plus encore
l'article 59 de la loi mapin prévoit
qu'en 2024 c'est-à-dire dans 2 mois
lesétoat doit redressuder aux
collectivités la charge d'un grand
nombre d'ouvrage de protection
aujourd'hui après mout alerte venue de
toute part à travers les amendements une
mission du Sénat point au gilet nous
arrivons tous à la même conclusion il
faut une solidarité territoriale à
ramorcer pour assurer la prévention des
inondations en commission aménagement du
territoire dernièrement monsieur le
ministre vous avez vous aussi indiqué
que cette solution serait avec votre
faveur ma question monsieur le ministre
est simple allez-vous sur soir cette
disposition de charge en 2024 et surtout
puisque le principe de solidarité est
acté quand allons-nous transformer ce
principe en acte je vous remercie pour
vous répondre parole est au ministre de
la transition écologique
monsieur monsieur le Président mesames
etessieurs sénateur monsieur le sénateur
rou d'abord vous l'avez dit un texte une
loi maptam qui a presque 10 ans et comme
souvent c'est quand on arrive dans les
derniers mois qui précèdent
l'application d'un terme de 10 ans que
la question de savoir ce qui a été fait
depuis 10 ans se pose je veux dire qu'il
y a de vraies disparités
territoriales dans la nuit du 14 au 15
novembre dans la Savoie dans la Haute
Savoie des crues très importantes ont
conduit à des dégâts élevés au-delà de
ce qu'on a pu voir dans le pas decalis
c'est passé un peu en dehors des radars
parce qu'il y a pas eu autant de
sinistrés mais les investissements
gmapis et notamment le papier réalisé en
2020 avec 44 millions d'euros de soutien
de l'État sur les 66 engagés ne sont pas
pour rien dans le fait qu'alors que nous
avons cru qui a battu le record de celle
de 2015 et qui est la plus haute depuis
depuis 1904 nous n'ayons pas eu autant
de dégâts que prévu qu'est-ce que j'ai
annoncé il y a quelques jours en
commission d'aménagement à court terme
c'est que dès le 1er janvier prochain
nous pourrions utiliser le fond vert y
compris dans les territoires qui
n'auraient pas levé la taque gmapi pour
pouvoir accélérer sur les systèmes
d'endigement mais le rendez-vous il va
un peu au-delà si vous voulez bien parce
que ce que vous pointez c'est qu'on est
sur une taxe par personne alors qu'on
est sur un risque qui dépend finalement
des surfaces des linéaires de fleuve et
des difficultés avec lesquelles on se
retrouve et là je vous prends au mot
monsieur le sénateur parce que vous avez
dit vous-même qu'on avait des dispositif
qui allit moins vite que le dérèglement
climatique et là l'enjeu il peut pas
être de regarder un jour les inondation
la semaine qui suit les éboulements la
troisème les sécheresses avec lesquelles
on se retrouve c'est l'adaptation
globale de notre système que nous devons
penser j'aurai l'occasion sous
l'autorité de la première ministre de
présenter en début d'année le programme
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique qui sort d'un dénis et qui
dit au rythme où vont les états sur le
plan mondial c'est à 4 degrés de
réchauffement que nous devons nous
préparer ce vol est là doit
s'accompagner d'une refonte des
catastrophes naturelles et d'une
évolution de nos dispositifs de
solidarité compte tenu de la
multiplication des fréquences c'est ce
rendez-vous de solidarité et de vérité
que nous aurons
bientôt la parole est à notre collègue
audre linkeneld pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il y a quelques jours dans son
état sur la pauvreté en France
l'association Caritas titrait les femmes
en première ligne en février c'est la
fondation abbépierre qui soulignait dans
son rapport annuel le mallogement au
féminin or les violences sociales
rendent les femmes particulièrement
vulnérables en cas de violence conjugale
210000 femmes subissent chaque année les
couts de leurs conjoints ou ex-conjoint
dans notre pays 121 sont mortes depuis
janvier et cela parce que notre société
n'a pas su les protéger je rappelle que
chaque femme victime de violence
effectue en moyenne six départs
infructueux avant de partir
définitivement partir quand le conjoint
ne peut être évincé c'est difficile pour
de multiples raisons il faut par exemple
assumer seul toutes les dépenses avec un
salaire inférieur en moyenne de 25 % et
puis il faut savoir où aller or une
femme sur six a besoin d'un hébergement
et quand l'offre de logement abordable
et adapté est insuffisante ce sont les
femmes victimes de violence qui en font
les frais
les collectivités le savent bien avec
des maires qui font face à de multiples
demandes sociales qui se télescopent et
les obligent à gérer d'abord la pénurie
tant que nos services publics essentiels
le logement la santé l'insertion
continueront d'être dégradés et
délaissés par l'État les femmes
resteront captives de ces déserts
médicaux immobiliers et sociaux alors
madame la ministre quand allez-vous
prendre conscience que les victimes que
de nombreux élus locaux que toutes les
hommes et les femmes qui March
marcheront le 25 novembre lors de la 24e
journée internationale pour
l'élimination des violences à l'égard
des femmes que tous attendent que la
grande cause que vous défendez se
traduise en fait par une réorientation
profonde de votre politique du logement
et de la
solidarité pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la lutte contre les discriminations
madame Beranger Couillard vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateur madame la sénatrice line Canel
je voulais déjà vous dire que la
préoccupation qui est la vôtre est
également la nôtre ça fait maintenant
depuis 6 ans que nous agissons avec
vraiment beaucoup de vigueur sur la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes vous avez raison le public
féminin les femmes en particulier de
notre pays gagnent moins que les hommes
et donc Infiné se retrouve dans des
situations parfois plus précaires
lorsqu'une femme est victime de violence
conjugale vous l'avez rappelé madame
sénatrice même si nous avons pas le même
chiffre j'ai SEP allers-retour en
moyenne mais quel que soient les
allés-retours c'est déjà beaucoup trop
et donc nous souhaitons accélérer les
départs des femmes faire en sorte
qu'elles puissent être mis à l'abri avec
leurs enfants pour cela vous savez nous
avons déjà développé de nombreux
dispositifs déjà beaucoup de lois ont
été votées ici cinq lois sur le premier
quinquena ici aussi et beaucoup de
dispositifs des dispositifs sur le
recueil de la parole des femmes des
dispositifs qui permettent aussi une
meilleure protection des femmes et des
dispositifs utile aussi pour une
meilleure sanction et traitement des
auteurs pour le départ des femmes vous
savez il y a évidemment l'hébergement
d'urgence que nous avons doublé depuis
2017 pour atteindre plus de 10000 places
d'hébergement et puis nous accompagnons
les femmes et facilitons le fait qu'elle
puisse partir plus facilement avec le
pack nouveau départ le pack nouveau
départ il sera disponible dans CIN
départements pilotes ça permettra
d'avoir un agent de la CAF coordinateur
qui avec l'aide des associations locales
facilit a le départ des femmes parce que
nous savons que les féminicides
adviennent malheureusement souvent au
moment de la séparation il est
indispensable de faire en sorte que les
femmes ne fassent plus SEP allers-retour
en moyenne mais beaucoup moins pour
sauver des vies et puis nous allons
mettre en place aussi l'aide universelle
d'urgence qui se met en place dans
l'ensemble des départements français et
donc ce sera une aide qui permettra
d'accompagner le départ des femmes parce
que souvent ce sont aussi des
contraintes financière vous l'avez dit
madame la sénatrice qui contraînent les
femmes et qui les empêche de partir de
leur domicile c'est bien l'objectif de
tous les dispositifs que nous déployons
merci vous avez quelques secondes ma
cher collègue le problème madame la
ministre c'est que vos positions
budgétaires contredisent en fait vos
déclarations c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre groupe déposera
l'amendement qui permettra de créer des
milliers de places d'hébergement attendu
par les associations pour les 2000
enfants à la rue pour les femmes et les
familles mal
logées la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Michel
Grum pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste et
canqui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nos communes sont à l'os elles n'ont
plus aucune marge baisse constante de la
DGF au fil des années et non indexation
sur l'inflation augmentation du poids
d'indice non compensé reprise d'un
compte sur le filet de sécurité et j'en
passe et les voici maintenant face au
casse-tête de la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat obligatoire dans les
deux deux autres versants de la fonction
publique sa mise en œuvre dans les
communes dépend certes du bon vouloir du
maire mais surtout des moyens financier
dont il dispose car bien souvent l'État
décide mais ne paye pas tout d'abord sur
le principe plus qu'une prime
facultative c'est bien d'une
reconnaissance pérenne et donc
d'augmentation de salaire en fonction de
l'inflation dont les gens ont besoin et
que dire de l'inégalité de traitement
entre les différentes catégories de
fonctionnaires et les agents
territoriaux eux-mêmes selon qu'il
travaillent dans une commune qui a ou
non les moyens de verser cette prime
beaucoup affichent déjà des difficultés
de recrutement sur certains emplois et
malgré leurs efforts nos mères se
sentent considérés comme de mauvais
élèves par le gouvernement à qui on
demande toujours de faire plus avec
toujours moins là sont les raisons du
malaise des maires de leur profonde
fatigue et de leur colère la moitié
d'entre eux estime ne pas avoir de
reconnaissance de l'État il ne demande
rien d'autre que de la considération du
respect et du soutien ce qui passe
d'abord par leur redonner les moyens et
les pouvoirs d'agir afin de répondre aux
besoins et aux attentes de leurs agents
communaux et de leur
administrer quelle réponse leur
apportez-vous monsieur le ministre
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur B monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice
grhum d'abord le hasard fait bien les
choses et il est heureux que vous posiez
une question sur le rôle des maires et
leur place au moment où se déroule
précisément le salon et le Congrès des
Maires de France et je ne doute pas dans
cette enceinte que vous n'êtes sans
doute pas la seule et votre groupe
politique n'est sans doute pas le seul à
considérer effectivement la République
doit se trouver au côté de ceux qui sont
en première ligne quel que soit les
sujets dont on parle dans ce domaine les
actes valent parfois nettement mieux que
les paroles quand j'entends de ce
côté-là de l'hémicycle des gens
expliquer que les communes sont àos et
que les dotations ne cesse de baisser je
dois vous rappeler que le quinquena de
François Hollande est
terminé et que les 10 milliards d'euros
de baisse de dotation qui ont eu lieu
entre 2012 et
2017 constitue précisément socle des
difficultés des collectivités venir
aujourd'hui en disant regardez dans un
espèce de jeu de bon tau jamais les
collectivité non eu si peu désolé mais
ça ne marche pas s' vous plaît monsieur
temal s'il vous plaît 13 ans sans hausse
c'est la deuxè année consécutive où la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
augmente au global sur l'année
2024 c'est 1illard millions de
compléments de crédit pour les
collectivités donc on peut dire
c'est pas assez mais on ne peut pas dire
ça n'existe pas 200 millions de DGF 100
millions de dotations de titre sécurisé
5 millions pour les violences faites aux
élus 11 millions pour les communes
nouvelles 100 millions pour les aménités
rurales 250 millions de FCTVA sur
l'aménagement 500 millions d'euros sur
le fond vert c'est la réalité
et qu'il y ait ici des gens qui soient
fâchés avec les chiffres c'est une chose
qui le soit avec la réalité c'est plus
gênant madame
gréot monsieur le ministre on est là
justement pour aider les municipalités
en aucun que le principe de libre
administration ne peut vous servir de
justification car celle-ci suppose
justement de pouvoir disposer librement
de ressources suffisantes ce qui n'est
clairement pas le cas
aujourd'hui la parole est à notre
collègue Isabelle Floren pour le groupe
de l'Union
centriste avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Fonction publique en
cette semaine on vient d'en parler où se
tient le congrès annuel de l'Association
des maires de France il faut
malheureusement constater que les sujets
d'inquiétude sur le bon fonctionnement
de nos communes et sur leur situation
financière sont bien réelles c'est
pourquoi je tiens à revenir sur l'un des
engagements pris par votre gouvernement
lors de la réforme des retraites en
effet dans le cadre de cette réforme il
a été programmé à partir de 2024 la
hausse d'un point de cotisation des
employeurs publics à la Caisse nationale
de retraite des agents des collectivités
locales dites CNRA cl selon certaines
estimations cette cette augmentation
pèsera sur les finances de nos communes
autour de 640 millions d'euros par an en
contrepartie vous vous étiez engagé à
compenser intégralement cette hausse et
cet engagement s'est traduit par
l'approbation à l'article 9 dans la loi
de finance rectificative de la sécurité
sociale en 2023 introduisant un principe
de compensation intégrale de celle-ci
dans les conditions à définir par la loi
or à ce jour aucune mesure technique n'a
été prise pour le rendre applicable plus
alarmement encore rien n'est mentionné
dans le projet de loi de finance 2024
pour les employeurs publics à la
différence du secteur privé cette hausse
étant compensée pour ces derniers par
une baisse à du concurrence des
cotisations accident du travail et
maladie professionnelle or monsieur le
ministre cette précision apportée pour
le secteur privé signifietelle que les
engagement pris pour les employeurs
publics est reporté à plus tard et si
tel n'est pas le cas je vous demande de
nous indiquer si des modalités de mise
en œuvre de cette promesse sont bien
prévu pour
2024 pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique monsieur Guerini merci Monsieur
le merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Isabelle Floren alors vous
m'interrogez sur les conditions de
financement et la contribution des
employeurs territoriaux hospitaliers à
la caisse de retraite des agents des
fonctionnaires territoriaux et
hospitaliers d'abord pour vous répondre
il faut porter un regard lucide sur la
situation financière de cette caisse de
retraite elle connaî d'ors déjà un
déficite un déficite qui va aller en
s'aggravant dans les années à venir
principalement d'ailleurs pour des
raisons de démographie il y avait pour
la fonction public hospitalire et
territorial quatre fonctionnaires actifs
pour un fonctionnaire retraité dans les
années 90 c'est
1,55 aujourd'hui ça sera à peine plus de
1 à l'horizon 2030 et c'est pour ça que
il y a un déficit de 1,2 milliard
d'euros au moment où nous nous parlons
et que les perspectives financières
c'est 8 milliards d'euros de déficit à
horizon 2030 et donc c'est dans ce
cadre-là que le gouvernement a annoncé
la hausse d'un point du taux de
cotisation des employeurs publics à
cette caisse de retraite mais à cette
annonce le gouvernement a ajouté un
engagement et il a été pris par madame
la Première ministre dans cette
assemblée de compensation intégrale de
cette hausse de cotisation je réitère
devant vous cet engagement aujourd'hui
alors il nous reste à fixer les
modalités techniques nous en avons
discuté avec les employeurs territo
a été évoqué un transfert de taux pour
réaliser cela c'est une question que le
gouvernement prend très au sérieux
puisque le gouvernement a missionné
trois inspections l'IGF l'IGA et l'IGAS
pour une mission d'inspection qui doit
rendre sur cette question ses
conclusions d'ici la fin du mois de
novembre pour que nous puissions
intégrer dans les textes financiers la
modalité de compensation de cette hausse
de taux et que cette modalité de
compensation interviennent
concomitamment à cette hausse de taux
j'ajoute que cette mission a pour
objectif de poser un diagnostic à la
demande des employeurs territoriaux et
hospitaliers et des pistes de
d'équilibrage de cette caisse de
retraite à moyen à long terme vous le
voyez madame la sénatrice nous avançons
en responsabilité mais nous avançons
aussi en transparence avec l'ensemble
des élus locaux et des employeurs
hospitaliers madame Floren
oui merci Monsieur précision vous
comprenez que à l'heure où les communes
préparent leur budget cette information
est primordiale et qu'il faut l'avoir
dans dans les plus brefs délaiis
maintenant donc nous attendons
effectivement le rapport pour les
employeur public c'est tout à fait
nécessaire et utile dans dans cette
prévision
budgétaire la parole est à notre
collègue matiile Olivier pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et
territoire merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Solidarités et de la
famille zéro enfants à la rue
c'est ce que vous promettiez il y a 1 an
nous sommes mi-nvembre la trêve
hivernale a commencé le froid s'installe
et pourtant madame la ministre ce soir
ce sont bien 2822 enfants qui dormiront
dehors votre politique de mise à l'abri
est donc un échec pire votre bilan s'est
alourdi c'est 20 % d'enfants en plus qui
vivent dehors voilà la réalité
l'hébergement d'urgence relève de la
responsabilité première et principale de
l'État mais aujourd'hui c'est la
solidarité citoyenne qui compense vos
failles madame la ministre h écoles à
Lyon se à Rennes SEP à Paris deux à
Grenoble ce sont 30 écoles qui sont
occupées la nuit pour permettre aux
enfants de dormir au chaud à l'hôpital
des femmes restent plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines pour ne pas repartir
à la rue avec leurs nouveaué nos maires
nos départements nos députés sont en
première ligne et se mobilisent ils vous
ont exprimé leur impuissance face à
cette situation nous attendons depuis
plusieurs semaines une réaction du
gouvernement il n'en est rien vous avez
choisi le camp du déni
nous vous avons demandé en urgence la
création de 10000 lieux d'hébergement en
plus à l'Assemblée nationale vous les
avez refusé et surtout ne me répondez
pas avec des excuses financières dans un
pays comme la France que représentent
10000 hébergements d'urgence en plus
face à des enfants des familles qui
dorment dans des écoles et qui vite le
matin doivent ranger les sacs de
couchage avant l'arrivée de leurs
copains que représentent ces budgets si
c'est pour sauver des vies alors
qu'est-ce que cette banalisation des
enfants dans la rue dit de notre société
madame la ministre
quand comptez-vous annoncer
l'augmentation des lieux d'hébergement
d'urgence pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'enfance madame Charlotte
cobel merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice Mathilde Olivier évidemment
dans la semaine des droits de l'enfant
avoir un enfant à la rue c'est
évidemment un enfant de trop le droit à
des conditions dignes de vie est un
droit fondamental reconnu par la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant le Gouvernement partage
pleinement les préoccupations qui sont
les vôtres sur la situation de ses
enfants et de ses familles face à ces
situations dramatiqu il prend
contrairement à ce que vous dites ses
responsabilités nous y avons encore été
attentifs à l'occasion du dernier comité
interministériel de l'enfance les
efforts déployés pour mettre à l'abri
n'ont jamais été aussi importants comme
en témoigne le maintien du parc
d'hébergement d'urgence à un très haut
niveau depuis 2017 il a eu constamment
de la création de places de mise à
l'abri et nous avons maintenu un niveau
de plus de 200000 places ouvertes chaque
année qui permet d'héberger 70000
enfants vous parlez de chiffres qui
évoluent constamment puisque des
familles arrivent constamment nous
plaçons nous accueillons des familles et
d'autres familles arrivent c'est bien
l'enjeu des flux et vous parlez en stock
madame des mesures intégrées dans le
PACT de solidarité permettent de
maintenir par ailleurs l'amélioration
des conditions de vie de de ses enfants
l'année dernière c'est plus de 3000
enfants qui ont été récupérés pour être
scolarisés par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans ces
hébergements à l'hôtel nous veillons à
la scolarisation des enfants à l'accès
aux soins à la création de lieux
alimentaires et de lieux de loisir pour
améliorer leurs conditions de vie mettre
à l'abri ses enfants ne doit pas nous
nous nous faire perdre un objectif
principal qui est l'accès à un logement
péren et là aussi le gouvernement est
profondément engagé l'accès au logement
social a permis d'accueillir plus de
240000 personnes l'année dernière avec
100000 enfants donc on est bien dans une
logique de sortir ses enfants aussi du
logement d'urgence nous souhaitons et
c'est important conduire cette politique
volontariste avec les le secteur
associatif les collectivités
territoriales pour attribuer des
logements sociaux aux personnes sortant
d'hébergement c'est notre engagement je
vous remercie madame
Olivier en 2017 le président de la
République disait qu'il ne voulait plus
voir de personne à la rue en attendant
maintenant c'est 2800 enfants qui sont à
la rue vous êtes au responsabilité
depuis 6 ans vous n'êtes pas à la
hauteur c'est votre politique qui amène
à cette catastrophe sociale ce n'est
plus l'heure de se défiler
réveillez-vous et ouvrez ces 10000
places d'hébergement
maintenant la parole est à notre
collègue Anne vantalon pour le gros PL
républicain
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait au
ministre de l'Intérieur dimanche 19
novembre les habitants de crépool
village de la Drome se sont réveillés
avec un sentiment d'incrédulité et des
froids j'associe donc à ma question mon
collègue sénateur de la Drome Gilbert
boucher qui ainsi que nous tous partage
la douleur de la famille de Thomas ainsi
que celle des blessés comme notre
collègues nous ne nous ne comprenons
plus ce qui arrive à notre pays
brutalisé jusque dans les territoires
les plus
épargnés les habitants de la ruralité
qui ne bénéficient pas des commodités de
la vie citadine en subissent à présent
les dérives les plus tragiques aux
agressions contre les élus vient
désormais s'ajouter l'attaque criminelle
d'un bal de village certes nos forces de
l'ordre agissent avec célérité pour
interpeller ceux qui à répondre de leurs
actes mais les Français sont Lass Lass
des marches blanches Lass des
sansiternelles annonces ministérielles
qui succèdent au drame or la flambée des
actes antisémites et des violences de
toutes sortes laisse à penser que la
prophétie de Gérard coland craignant que
demain on ne vive face à face ne soit
déjà
réalisé aussi au-delà de l'émotion que
nous ressentons aujourd'hui aujourd'i ma
question porte sur les qure prochaines
années de ce quinquen qu'envisage le
gouvernement à moyen et long terme pour
qu'il redevienne inconcevable que dans
ce pays on agresse le médecin
l'institutrice le maire comment
allez-vous restaurer la valeur de
l'autorité qui rend naturel le respect
des uniformes et des services publics et
la crainte de subir les rigueurs de la
loi monsieur le ministre Albert cam
écrit
que le but d'un écrivain est d'empêcher
la civilisation de se détruire alors
dites-nous si c'est aussi l'objectif du
gouvernement et comment il compte y
parvenir je vous remercie on vous répond
la parole
est monsieur le garde desau é Dupont
Moretti merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice
vantalon face à face je ne sais pas nous
devons être unis en
l'occurrence dans le silence et dans le
recueillement et même si les mots sont
dérisoires voyez-vous je fais bien les
mots de monsieur le Président Larcher
tels qu'il les a exprimé il y a de cela
quelques minutes avec mesure et
compassion pour vous faire une
confidence toute honte bu hier pour
rendre hommage à ce ce gosse j'étais
interpellé par l'un de vos collègues je
lui ai donné le prénom de l'un de mes
enfants
ça n'est évidemment pas vous l'imaginez
bien de la désinvolture mais c'est le
fait que chacun d'entre nous ici nous
nous disons mais cet enfant ça pouvait
être le
nôtre la famille a demandé à ce qu'il
n'y a aucune exploitation politicienne
vous le savez comment on peut répondre à
cela ici en quelques secondes en
rappelant que nous avons renforcé
considérablement bien sûr le nombre de
policiers de gens armes de magistrat de
greffiers grâce d'ailleurs au vote qui a
été sollicité ici devant vous et que
vous avez accepté de donner au
gouvernement moi je veux remercier ici
les forces de sécurité intérieure pour
leur rapidité les pompiers également je
veux remercier la délégué
interministériel de l'aide aux victimes
qui est intervenu je veux remercier
l'association d'aide aux victimes France
victime de la drô et puis je veux vous
dire que le ministère de la justice
c'est le ministère des victimes que les
auteurs seront châtiés à la hauteur de
leur crime par une cour d'assise
composée majoritairement de français
comme vous et
[Applaudissements]
moi la parole est à notre cègue remémi
pore pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues ma question concerne l'avenir
des des zones de revitalisation rurale
les arr existent depuis
1995 et les élus locaux y sont très
attachés car elles ont été créées pour
venir en aide aux territoires ruraux ce
dispositif est fondamental pour
redynamiser le commerce artisanat mais
également pour favoriser l'installation
des professionnels de santé dans les
territoires les plus fragiles certains
membres de votre majorité ont souvent
voulu faire la peau des éires mais
c'était sans compter sur le Sénat qui a
toujours œuvré pour les préserver
notamment en pourant leur
existence aujourd'hui ce dispositif doit
être réformé tout le monde en convient
et au sein de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire nous avons
beaucoup travailler sur ce sujet depuis
3 ans un travail qui abouti au dépôt
d'une proposition de loi qui permet
zonage plus juste plus ciblé et plus
efficace pour 19000 communes vous
proposez une réforme inscrite à
l'article 7 du PLF 2024 malheureusement
dans l'état actuel elle s'éloigne de nos
préconisations vous conservez la maille
intercommunale alors que le Sénat et
l'ensemble des associations d'élus
souhaitent la maille communale vos
critères retenus ne permettent pas
d'apprécier la diversité des situations
de la ruralité pire encore vous vous
apprêtez à intégrer des aires urbaines
dans un zonage rural avec l'intégration
de villes de plus de 25000 habitants ce
qui est contraire au bon sens
conséquence dans l'état actuel de votre
réforme seulement 13600 communes seront
classées contre plus de 17000
aujourd'hui ma question est simple en
envisagez-vous de corriger votre copie
et de vous rapprocher de nos
recommandations pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de la cohésion
des
territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président poter
oui votre question c'est envisagez-vous
de corriger l'article 7 du PLF la
réponse est
oui comment
figurez-vous que ça c'est la première
ministre qui donnera le détail précis de
de ce que je
m'apprête
je comprends je comprends que vous la
réclamiez mais le règlement des
questions gouvernement fait que quand un
ministre s'est levé il est obligé
d'aller au terme de sa réponse alors
monsieur le Président point trop
plusieurs choses 1 1 je veux d'abord
rendre hommage et vous me permettra de
le faire dans l'ordre au sénateur delcro
et à la sénatrice d'espagac qui a
l'occasion d'un rapport consacré au
devenir des RR on dit on peut pas
arrêter au 31 décembre il faut même
imaginer un système à double cliquet ZRR
zrr+ 2 à la Commission de l'aménagement
je fais pas seulement référence à nos
échanges y compris en dehors de cette
commission monsieur le Président poterau
je salue l'ancien maire de l'asnet je
salue l'ancien président du département
du Cher je sais que ce sujet c'est pas
une posture c'est la réalité d'un combat
de près de 40 ans au-delà de ça 1 il y a
la question du nombre de communes vous
avez raison de dire qu'avec 13000 si on
est en dessous du chiffre actuel alors
même que c'est 4 8 % du territoire qui
est couvert par des zones c'est sans
doute que nos critères ne sont pas les
bons 2 le principe de dire on prend tout
un département entraîne les effets de
bord que vous indiquez sur des
préfectures départementales là où en
première intention il y avait une
volonté d'aller faire dans la simplicité
pour dire on a des territoires qui sont
déprises démographique et qui ont par
ailleurs des indicateurs qui pourrai
conduire à les aider mais si on met dans
la même catégorie une ville de 200 une
ville de 20000 le risque qu'on choisisse
la ville de 20000 au détriment de la
ville de 200 et qu'il faudra réinventer
d'autres dispositifs 3 il reste le sujet
de la maille et là-dessus il n'est pas
certain qu'on se retrouve complètement
parce que depuis 95 il y a au moins une
chose qui est constante c'est la maille
intercommunale mais ce que nous
souhaitons c'est le rattrapage communal
pour qu'on soit certain d'éviter les
effets de bord dans très peu de temps la
première ministre vous dira ce qu'elle
attend et vous pourrez l'applaudir comme
il se
doit monsieur point TR oui monsieur le
ministre je me réjouis que finalement le
le Sénat ait réussi à vous faire reculer
sur un projet initial qui était
disons-le ni fait ni à faire toutefois
j'observe que l'on traite de nouveau la
ruralité avec une certaine désinvolture
puisque on fait un amendement de
dernière minute et je pense que la
revitalisation des territoires mérite
beaucoup mieux que cela merci à
vous la parole est à notre collègue
Audré bellim pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué aux outres
mèes et à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances concernant la
réforme de l'octroi de mer outil
précieux et essentiel pour nos
collectivités territoriales oui nous
sommes à une très large majorité élus
nationaux ou locaux habitants ou
entrepreneurs largement favorbl à sa
remise à plat pour la rendre plus
lisible plus efficiente et plus simple
plus lisible pour nos compatriotes qui
ne doivent pas ir taxer des produits
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de
concurrence pays plus efficient pour nos
collectivités plus simple sur le plan
administratif comme financier pour nos
TPE PME à l'origine l'octroit de mer a
été pensé pour protéger les économies
locales de la concurrence extérieure
parce que moins compétitive car
insulaire ou éloigné de l'Hexagone
étonnamment alors qu'elle ne devait
concerner que les produits de
l'extérieur elle s'applique désormais
paradoxalement aux produits locaux
pourtant bien réformé cette taxe peut
devenir un véritable levier pour la
structuration de nos filières
économiques un levier de création
d'emploi et de développement face à la
concurrence dans chacun de nos bassins
géographiques depuis 2017 force est de
constater que les réformes concernant
les outrmèes comme d'autres se sont pour
la plupart fait sans les outresmes
l'intérêt comptable à très court terme
est trop souvent passé devant
l'investissement et l'intérêt des
comptes publics à long terme et cela
sans concertation la réforme des aides
économiques ou encore plus récemment
l'amendement au sein du PL 2024 sans
étude d'impact du rapporteur général du
budget à l'Assemblée nationale et fondé
sur un rapport peu flatteur pour notre
haute administration ainsi vous
engagez-vous messieurs les ministres à
associer les élus nationaux et locaux
les représentants des consommateurs et
des entreprises pour aboutir à une
réforme de l'octroi de merire consentie
par toutes et
tous pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des l'reert
Monsieur Philippe Vigier merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la signénatrice audre
BIM vous savez qu'après l'appel de Fort
de France il y a eu de la part du
gouvernement la volonté de bâtir un
nouvel avenir pour les outrem qui se
traduit par 72 mesures qu'on appelle le
si le comité interministériel de
outoutrem et socium son premier bilan
d'étape aura lieu jeudi et vendredi donc
demain et après-demain à Paris et parmi
ces 72 mesure il y en a une la première
c'est pas moi qui l'ai rédigé elle a été
rédigé ainsi par tous les acteurs de
socium c'est de faire une réforme en
profondeur de justement cet octroi de
maire dont vous avez souligné vous-même
le caractère injuste le caractère
inégalitaire et puis qui au départ taxer
les importations et qui maintenant taxe
même la production des produits locaux
avec Bruno le ma avec géralde LAN nous
avons établi une méthode et un
calendrier la méthode vous venez
demander si ou non les élus locaux ser
associés bien sûr ils le seront
d'ailleurs on vient d'écrire au
président de collectivité et au
président de l'association des mares les
parlementaires naturellement seront
associés le monde économique lu sera
également il y aura une première
rencontre avec eux dès le mois de
décembre prochain selon le calendrier
donné par la première ministre cette
réforme nous avons toute l'année 2024
pour l' porter parce qu'elle doit se
traduire dans le budget 2025 et en
application en 2027 oui nous garantirons
les recettes des communes et des
collectivités oui nous voudrons lutter
contre la vie chère avec cette
application inégale de trit même sur des
denrées de première nécessité don cette
réforme est indispensable c'est ensemble
que nous la ferons sinon il y aura pas
de
réforme merci Madame
Belline non vous ne souhaitez pas
intervenir alors madame porgot Fontain
pour le groupe les républicains vous
avez la
parole ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre gestion de la commune
option autodéfense voici désormais le
nouveau module de formation proposé au
maire notamment dispensé par le Raid
prochaine étape peut-être qu'il
deviennent finalement des militaires à
part entière cette augmentation
croissante des agressions des élus et
notamment des injures anonymes en ligne
et celle des démissions en cascade des
mares est devenue le maronier de
l'assemblée générale des Maes de France
symbole de l'échec de notre République
en cause le délitement de l'autorité et
la contestation quasi systématique de
leur décision malgré les discours de
fermeté et d'indignation les postures
martial même du gouvernement la
situation ne fait que se dégrader les
récentes annonces dont la création d'un
numéro vert pour les élus qui existent
déjà d'ailleurs à la MF ne suffiront pas
prenons le bras à bras le corp cette
dérive qui conduit à l'ensauvagement de
la société cette perte de l'autorité de
l'État c'est le problème majeur de notre
pays sans une extrême fermeté vis-à-vis
de ceux qui font désormais de la
violence un mode d'expression comme un
autre nous n'y arriverons pas et je suis
fier d'appartenir au groupe les
républicains qui a su dès le premier
tirer la sonnette d'alarme sur ce fléo
et mettre des propositions fortes
adoptées ici même le mois dernier madame
la Première ministre la situation est
intenable la République va mal nos édyes
sont inquiets vos annonces nous les
connaissons mais rassurez-nous de
nouvelles mesures sont-elles prévues
afin que nos maires puissent enfin
exercer leur mandat sans avoir
l'angoisse de se faire
agresser pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État en charge de
la citoyenneté de la ville Sabrina
Agresti roubach vous avez la parole
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice
borquef la protection des élus est une
priorité vous avez raison de le
souligner elle concourt à la protection
de la République dans son entièreté or
nous faisons face depuis un an et vous
avez raison à une recrudescence des
violences qui se sont manifesté à
plusieurs reprises par des agressions
particulièrement AB sur nos élus les
élus locaux et notamment les maires sont
les premiers exposés à ce phénomène
si le nombre de violence physique si le
nombre pardon de violence physique
n'augmente pas les menaces et les
outrages se multiplie le gouvernement
s'est engagé pour mieux mesurer le
phénomène mieux prévenir les atteintes
des élus mieux sanctionner ceux qui les
attaquent c'est une mobilisation
générale qui a été lancée pour rendre
possible une un nécessaire choc civique
concrètement un Pack Sécurité élu et un
plan national de lutte contre les
violences faites aux élus a été mis en
place ces mesures sont financées à à
hauteur et le ministre le rappel de 5
millions d'euros pour 2024 d'ors et déjà
3400 référents élus policiers et
gendarmes sont dédiés à ce phénomène les
préfets et les procureurs ont réuni dans
chaque arrondissement les élus bientôt
des boutons d'alarme seront déployés des
dispositifs de vidéo prototection dédiés
seront installés le Centre national le
kalaé a été créé pour suivre le
phénomène et coordonner la mise en œuvre
de ces mesures il s'assure du suivi
individuel quasi quotidien d'une 50 de
cas le ministre de l'Intérieur et le
ministre de la justice sont au travail
lundi dernier un numéro d'assistance
psychologique destiné aux élus à leur
famille a été activé en lien avec France
victime cette semaine un premier point
d'Ét d'étape sera fait lors du congrès
des maires organisés par laamf vous le
savez par ma collègue Dominique fort qui
rencontrera les maires en compagnie des
magistrats des gendarmes des policiers
le diagnostic est est désormais clair
les moyens sont mis en place et je
m'assurai que les résultats soient à la
hauteur de la mobilisation et j'espère
que vous le ferez avec nous je vous
remercie madame Bor
fontin comme on s'y attendait madame la
ministre vous avez listé finalement les
mesures déjà annoncées par votre
gouvernement sont traités les causes de
ce fléo ni'y prendre de nouvelles
mesures il est temps en tout cas de se
donner enfin les moyens de stopper cette
crise civique majeure dont les violences
aux élus en sont une triste illustration
puis c'est aussi aux causes qu'il faut
s'attaquer alors plutôt que d'apprendre
en classe la théorie du genre à nos
enfants peut-être serait-il plus utile
d'apprendre à respecter nos élus nos
institutions et les valeurs de la
République la parole est à notre
collègue Dominique Verrien pour le
groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre un chiffre pour
commencer
244300 vous le savez c'est le nombre de
victimes de violence conjugale pour
l'année 2022 pour ces victimes
principalement des femmes sortir du
cycle de la violence est un véritable
parcours du combattant parfois la
victime ne travaille pas c'est
d'ailleurs un moyen pour le conjoint
violent de la contrôler quand il ne lui
confisque pas directement ses ressources
lorsqu'elle travaille or l'autonomie
financière est un préalable
indispensable à la rupture face à ce
constat notre notre collègue sénatrice
Valérie léard a fait adopter à
l'unanimité du Parlement Sénat et
Assemblée nationale sa proposition de
loi en février dernier notre collègue
josphine guidez en était d'ailleurs
rapporteur un texte instaurant une aide
universelle
d'urgence il est regrettable d'ailleurs
que Valérie lettard n'ait pas été
associée à l'élaboration des décret
décret que nous attendons encore et vous
le savez sans doute depuis Lausanne le
Sénat est sensible sur le sujet des
décrets j'ai donc trois questions en
rapport avec ce texte madame la ministre
1 à quand le décret d'application 2
cette loi instaure un soutien financier
versé par la CAF quel budget y sera-t-il
consacré selon quelle modalité le décret
le précise-t-il 3 toujours dans cette
PPL devenue loi était prévu
l'instauration d'une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes à
quand cette loi pres
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre en charge de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes madame Beranger
Couillard merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la Présidente
Verrien vous avez rappelé il y a eu
244000 signalements aux forces de
l'ordre pour l'année
2022 ce n'est ce n'est pas que les qu'il
y a plus de victimes mais c'est que les
femmes parlent d'avantage ell n'était
que 120000 en 2010 T et donc ça montre
qu'on a un changement qui s'opère au
sein de de notre société nous agissons
maintenant depuis 6 ans sans relâche
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et je tiens à vous dire que nous
agissons sur tous les leviers le premier
le recueil de la parole des femmes des
victimes la protection aussi bien sûr
des victimes et puis également la
sanction et le traitement des auteurs
vous avez évoqué madame la sénatrice
notamment l'aide universelle d'urgence
qui viendra également accompagner le
pack nouveau départ l'aide universelle
d'urgence c'est une aide qui provient
donc d'un travail qui a été réalisé par
votre ancienne collègue Valérie lettard
et donc qui a été voté ici à l'unanimité
dans cet hémicycle et je tiens
évidemment à saluer le travail des
sénateurs et vous dire que ce travail il
est essentiel parce qu'il va permettre
d'accompagner financièrement ces femmes
au départ il s'agit d'une d'une aide qui
va être octroyée par la CAF en 3 à 5
jours ouvrés cette aide elle sera
disponible à partir du 1er décembre à la
à la demande de la première ministre
pourquoi parce que normalement c'était
effectif début janvier et nous avons
souhaité avancer ce dispositif parce que
nous sommes persuadés qu'aider
financièrement les femmes sera
évidemment bénéfique pour ces femmes qui
ont besoin de partir et donc c'est une
aide qui sera de 243 € à
plus de 1300 € par exemple pour une
femme qui touche le SMIC qui a trois
enfants ce sera 1377 € qui seront touché
par qui sera touché par cette femme et
donc ça permettra d'adevenir aux
premières dépenses et vous savez
qu'elles peuvent être nombreuses
lorsqu'on quitte le domicile
précipitamment madame
verien merci madame la ministre pour
votre engagement alors je me permets
quand même de préciser que c'est bien
tris 5 jours mais si on met 15 jours à
avoir le premier rendez-vous à la CAF et
c'est le problème dans nos départements
on sait bien que ces services sont
plutôt engorgés ça risque d'être
compliqué le Nord qui a fait cette
expérimentation a des dispositifs qui
permettent de faire une une demande
immédiate par les services sociaux du
département ou même carrément par les
commissariats de telle sorte qu'on évite
ce temps de d'avoir accès à la CAF donc
ma demande c'est dans le décret précisez
le
bien
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Gérard premier pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues après la première rencontre de
Saint-Denis vous avez madame la Première
ministre lancé une mission temporaire
ayant pour objet la clarification de
l'action publique territoriale et
l'identification de nouvell piste de
décentralisation pourtant nombre de
maires et d'élus locaux sont plus
demandeurs d'une clarification de
l'action publique nationale et de leur
moyen d'agir dans un cadre déconcentré
clarification des décisions de l'État
dans les finances locales et les
compétences transférées clarification du
rôle des innombrables et coûteuses
agences nationales qui diluent les
responsabilités crée de la norme
supplémentaire et complique l'action des
collectivités clarification des appels à
projet qui se multiplient à l'envie dans
des cal endrier souvent très court
défavorisant les petites collectivités
dépourvues d'ingénierie pour des
montants financiers justifiant plus
souvent un pilotage préfectoral
déconcentré qu'un pilotage
ministériel clarification de la
succession de programme d'État qui donne
le tourni aux communes et sont rarement
évalués action corps- de ville contrat
de ruralité opération revitalisation des
territoires territoires d' d'industrie
territoire énergie positive à croissance
verte territoire de souriété foncière
crte petite ville de demain village
d'avavenir clarification enfin des
règles d'attribution des dotations
déconcentrées dont les périmètres et les
critères ne facilité par la tâche des
mares pour les dossiers à remplir des e
terres des îles fond vert monsieur le
ministre après la 2uxè rencontre de
saint-denier en même temps que la
mission vert le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de lancer une mission
temporaire ayant pour objet la
clarification de l'action publique
nationale et des moyens d'agir des
maires dans un cadre déconcentré et
pourquoi pas de la confier à de la Haute
Assemblée chambre des
territoires pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la prition écologique
et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
pommier d'abord aux alentours de
12h30 je pense que les oreilles d'une
partie des sénateurs je pense à louis-
Jean Nicolaï je pense à Françoise Gattel
mais président retillot à bien d'autres
ont d
teinté d'un bruit assez doux à leurs
oreilles qui a été le compliment que
j'ai adressé à la haute
assemblée au salon des mares en
officialisant une charte entre les
agences pour faire en sorte que ce que
vous avez dénoncé comme étant une
agentiarisation rampante d'une partie de
l'État se traduisent par des portes
d'entrée simplifié avant d'imaginer un
big bang avec aide territoire qui permet
aujourd'hui à un maire de pas se
demander quel est le bon opérateur
qu'elle la porte d'entrée mais de se
dire qu'il connaît une adresse c'est
celle de sa préfecture et
potentiellement un lien pour ensuite
pouvoir bénéficier du soutien de l'État
et je voulais le dire parce que c'est un
élément de réponse ensuite vous
m'interrogez indirement sur la mission
verte en me demandant si en parallèle de
cette mission il faudrait pas en lancer
une autre j'ai tendance à reprendre le
début de votre plaidoyer monsieur le
sénateur Pomier celui qui consiste à
dire que nous avons besoin de mettre de
la clarté là où on peut parfois donner
le sentiment qu'il y a un peu de
superposition je ne crois pas qu'une
superposition de mission dans le même
temps participera la clarté il y a une
mission confiée à erict cette mission
elle consiste à regarder ce que sont les
perspectives potentielles de
déconcentration de
décentralisation la question des moyens
et la question du statut des élus il va
pouvoir s'appuyer sur des travaux qui
existent déjà sur des rencontres avec
des élus qui sont présents en faire une
synthèse et être capable d'apporter un
une proposition globale je pense que
c'est à ce moment-là dans quelques mois
puisque les délais sont courts qui
conviendra de regarder y compris avec le
Parlement les directions dans lesquelles
il faut avancer plutôt que d'avoir en
parallèle plusieurs démarches avec le
risque à la fin de perdre un peu tout le
monde est-ce que nous souhaitons de la
simplification oui est-ce que nous
souhaitons de la décentralisation oui
est-ce que nous souhaitons diminuer les
appels à projet oui c'est le sens de
l'action que je mène depuis 500 jours
sous l'autorité d'Élisabeth borne et on
va continuer monsieur Jean-Gérard
Pomier merci monsieur le ministre de
votre non réponse à la question posée
puissent vos décisions concrètes en la
matière donner agent de la fontaine qui
qui disait ne faut-il que délibérer la
cour en conseiller foisonne a-il besoin
d'exécuter il n'y a plus
personne la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Marc fousfort pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la dernière enquête
de l'association des maires de France et
du cvipof confirme le malaise des élus
loc locau confrontés à l'affaiblissement
de leur pouvoir d'agir la diminution de
la DGF en euros constant les compétences
que l'État ne transfère plus mais qu'en
réalité il abandonne aux collectivités
sans leur attribuer les moyens adaptés
l'amenuisement des leviers fiscaux voilà
les difficultés qui freinent
l'engagement des élus locaux à cela
s'ajoute l'urgence d'apporter une
réponse aux communes qui font face à la
complexification de l'accès aux
assurances dans un contexte de crise à
répétition depuis le début du mandat
1300 maires ont déjà démissionné parmi
les raisons mentionnées dans les
résultats de l'enquête les élus placent
en seconde position les relations de
plus en plus complexes avec l'État sur
ce sujet ce n'est pas aux élus locaux de
faire des efforts mais bien à l'état car
ce qui décourage les élus c'est la
multiplication des appels à projets
c'est la mise en place d'une
réglementation technocratique excessive
sur des sujets pourtant essentiels comme
la transition écologique l'application
du zan en est un parfait exemple en
réalité le choc de simplification tant
attendu s'est transformé en choc de
suradministration monsieur le ministre
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
lutter concrètement contre ces obstacles
qui découragent les 500000 élus de notre
pays et qui porte atteinte à notre
démocratie
locale pour vous
répondre monsieur le
ministre de la cohésion des c'est normal
c'est la semain monsieur
ministre monsieur le Président mesames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur il y a peu de temps encore vous
étiez ma
deor et vousz per je pense entre votre
prier votre deè mandat le fait que dans
les attentes de la population y compris
dans la manière dont s'exprime parfois
les
revendications rien ne va dans le sens
de la modération en l'espace de quelques
années et le covid y a sans doute était
aussi pour quelque chose dans le
maintien de gestes barrière inconscient
par rapport à une partie de nos
concitoyens et de nos voisins il y a un
degré d'agressivité supplémentaire qui
s'est invité dans le débat public je
l'ai vécu comme mère je ne doute pas que
beaucoup ici l'ont vécu aussi dans le
même
temps il faut avoir la justesse de
reconnaître que ce chiffre de démission
il est effrayant mais qui n'est que 10 %
supérieur à ce qu'on avait au dernier
mandat dans dans un contexte où une
partie des difficultés que vous
déccrivez n'était pas exactement les
mêmes trois choses un
oui l'État a prendre sa part et quand je
dis prendre sa part à la fois parce
qu'il organise les règles du jeu est-ce
que parfois il les définit et à entendre
que en particulier dans les plus petites
communes il y a pas seulement lesnormme
il y a la réunionite moi j'entend des ma
m'expliquer que entre les périmètres de
Scott les pays là où ils existent les
pcaet les intercommunalités il y a un
moment où le temps dont ils disposent
pour être chez eux fini aussi par peser
sur d'autres équilibres que des
équilibres municipaux et
budgétaires j'entends au-delà de ça qui
a clairement la question du statut même
si dans cette enquête de svipof les Mr
disent pas d'abord payez-nous plus
aidez-nous davantage on ne peut pas à un
moment se retrouver à gérer autant de
contraintes autant de pression en nayant
plus une forme de reconnaissance qui
malheureusement ne se décrète pas par la
loi mais qui a disparu dans le regard
d'une partie de nos concitoyens et qui a
été remplacé par des insultes et par de
la violence et puis enfin il y a plus
largement la question des moyens à la
fois des collectivités territoriales
dans leur bloc et des communes à
l'intérieur de ce bloc et là on a un
double niveau entre votre interpellation
l'enquête CVIP et le rapport d'Arnaud je
ne doute pas que nous avons matière à
pouvoir avancer en attendant les
conclusions de la
missionsieur
ministreend mesure que vous êtes prêt à
avancer mais nous avons besoin sur ce
sujet d'une action d'ampleur et nous ne
nous contenterons pas d'un numéro vert
d'une aè mission sur la décentralisation
ou d'un florilège de plan qui se résume
souvent à de simples opérations de
communication dans mon département comme
ailleurs les agriculteurs ont inversé
les panneaux à l'entrée de nos communes
pour exprimer leur mécontentement face
au retard du versement de leurs aides
ils sont les victimes d'un transfert de
compétences vers les régions opéré sans
l'accompassation financière et humaine
nécessaire comme les élus locaux les
agriculteurs font face à un étau
administratif qui se
resserre monsieur le ministre ne nous
obligez pas à prendre le relais de ce
mouvement à force de vouloir bouleverser
notre échelon de proximité nous allons
nous aussi finir par marcher sur la
tête la parole est à notre collègue
Pauline Martin pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la
parole merci merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse s'adressait à
Madame la Ministre chargée des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité qui est remplacé par madame la
secrétaire d'État chargée de la
citoyenneté et de la ville en mai
dernier mon collègue sénateur Hux Sori
vous interpellez sur l'intolérable
abandon de nos collectivités face à
l'organisation d'événement de grande
ampleur de gens du voyage il vous
rappelait ainsi toutes les difficultés
rencontrées dans le Loiret par la
commune de neevvois et de l'ensemble du
bassin de vie du génois face à l'afflu
de 40000 pèlerins de l'association vie
et lumière grâce à la mobilisation de
tous un second rassemblement prévu pour
août dernier a finalement été déplacé
sur l'ancienne base aérienne de Grot
tanquin en Mosel et nous vous en
remercions très sincèrement c'est
peut-être moins le cas de nos collègues
de
Mosel tout comme neuvois et ses
alentours les communes voisines de cette
base aérienne ont eu à subir durant 2
semaines des les inévitables nuisances
que provoque un rassemblement d'une
telle ampleur pour un territoire non
dimensionné pour le recevoir l'État
prenant ses responsabilités a annoncé
jeudi 19 octobre dernier que les
communes de Mosel ayant subi ce
rassemblement toucheraient 1,5 million
d'euros de compensation c'est une
décision que je souhaite saluer et qui
m'a paraît indispensable aussi vous
comprendrez le triple sens de ma
question de quelle façon l'état
envisage-t-il d'accompagner le prochain
rassemblement en le limitant à 20000
pèlerins à neu vois du 28 avril au 5 mai
prochain est-il prévu un soutien
financier pour les communes du Loiré et
enfin quelle anticipation pour le 2è
rassemblement du mois d'août 2024 et
surtout où nos
voyageurs seront-ils
accueillis pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État en charge de
la citoyenneté et de la ville monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice Martin
merci pour votre question vous
m'interpellez donc et vous avez
interpellé au départ ma collègue
Dominique fort sur la question du site
de l'association Vie et Lumière à
neuvoie dans le Loiré et sur les
modalités d'organisation de leur
rassemblement annuel sur place qui
réunit habituellement 40000 personnes
vous avez fait mention des mesures
d'accompagnement que nous avons pris
récemment au bénéfice des communes qui
ont accueilli le rassemblement de gros
tanquin comme vous le savez l'État a dû
trouver la solution la plus adaptée pour
accueillir ce rassemblement dans les
meilleures conditions possibles il s'est
finalement tenu sur le site de la base
aérienne vous faites bien de le rappeler
appartenant à l'État habituellement
affecté à des activités
opérationnelles agissant de ce
rassemblement particulier l'État a tenu
à compenser les collectivités
territoriales affectées par les
dégradations liées à la tenue de cet
événement dans la mesure où c'est l'État
qui a fait le choix de ce terrain
s'agissant cependant d'un terrain privé
appartenant à une association dans le
Loiré que vous soullignez une peut-être
question d'un accompagnement financier
identique comme vous le comprendrez sans
doute ces deux situations sont
différente même si je comprends que les
communes de nevois et des alentours
demandent un accompagnement dédié cet
accompagnement existe bien sûr mais il
n'est pas de même nature à N voie l'État
est présent pour accompagner sécuriser
le rassemblement comme chaque année la
préfecture du Loiré mettra en œuvre tous
les moyens nécessaires pour que
l'organisation de ce rassemblement ne
perturbe pas la vie du territoire et ne
dégénère pas et ne génère pas de
dégradation locale dans tous les cas
l'État sera à vos côtés si des dégâts
sont commis pour mettre l'association
devant ses responsabilités et lui
présenter les factures afférentes nous
travaillons déjà avec l'association pour
lui soumettre une convention financière
qui permettra de mieux anticiper et de
mieux répondre à vos questions et vos
questions sont absolument légitime je
vous remercie madame
Martin merci madame la secrétaire d'État
une fois de plus nous constatons
l'immobilisme de l'État face à la
désérance des ma des maires face aux
gens du
voyage
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jceline Antoine pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur
F il n'a pas pu vous
échapper que depuis le début de la
semaine de nombreux panneaux d'entrée de
nos communes sont retrouvé à l'envers et
oui
ou échanger
le message est clair on marche sur la
tête ce sont les jeunes agriculteurs de
nos départements qui nous le disent
l'action est peut-être anecdotique mais
leur combat les moins les agriculteurs
ont engagé une transition dans leurs
exploitation une transition pour le
renouvellement des générations une
transition énergétique une transition
environnementale pourtant on continue de
faire pression sur leur prix ce n'est
pas une pression que nos agriculteurs
souhaitent mais une vision monsieur le
ministre et la vôtre manque clairement
d'ambition la politique agricole du
gouvernement est incohérente vous
imposez le respect des normes aux
agriculteurs alors même que la plupart
des produits importés n'y répondent pas
la coupe est pleine le monde agricole
exprime son
exaspération et pourtant c'est encore
avec des actions sndicale respectueuse
des biens et des personnes que les
agriculteurs nous alertent cette semaine
alors Monsieur le Ministre ma question
est simple quelle mesure durable et
connectée à la réalité de terrain
allez-vous prendre pour redonner du
souffle de la compétitivité et de
l'espoir à nos
agriculteurs merci pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire
monsieur Marc feno vous avez la
parole président merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice ce n'est
pas une action anecdotique elle vient
interpeller le gouvernement vient tous
nous interpeller sur la trajectoire que
nous voulons alors vous demandez qu'on
vous réponde sur la question de quelle
est la trajectoire et quels son
objectifs alors au cas vous ne les ayez
pas discerné d'abord la première
objectif c'est un objectif de
rémunération c'est les lois égalim 1
égalim 2 les lois la loi des crousailles
qui a été voté dans vos dans les deux
assemblées qui ont permis de travailler
sur la rémunération même s'il y a des
progrès à faire je ne croiserai pas un
agriculteur vous ne croiserez pas un
agriculteur qui dit disent qu'il F
supprimer ses lois faut aller plus loin
mais on sait que sur un certain nombre
de produits la question la rémunération
est importante le deuxième sujet pour
vous donner des éléments concrets parce
que j'ai l'impression que vous en
manquiez sur la question des assurances
nous avonsé nous avons voté vous avez
voté à l'Assemblée nationale et ici au
Sénat un texte qui vient profondément
modifier qui vient profondément modifier
le système assurentiel et qui vient
garantir la résilience du système puis
après il faut qu'on ait un cap le cap
qu'on a c'est le cap de la souveraineté
et le cap de la transition parce qu'il y
aura pas l'un sans l'autre pour que nous
puissions assumer la souverainé on a
besoin d'assumer aussi des transitions
en particulier cell lié au dérèglements
climatiques et pour ça nous avons un
outil qui a été travaillé avec les
professionnels agricoles qui est celui
de la planification nous avons besoin de
planification pour voir les si les
injonctions que nous souhaitons les
objectifs d'augmentation de production
de biomasse de souveraineté alimentaire
peuvent permettre de répondre aux autres
injonctions que nous avons sur l'eau sur
les produits phytosanitaires ça c'est
les objets de planification puis
troisème sujet pour être crédible nous
avons besoin de moyens et ça c'est le
budget que vous examinerez prochainement
c'est plus d' 1,3 milliard d'euros sur
l'année 2024 c'est un budget sans
précédent en terme d'augmentation et
sans précédent en terme de montant donc
une trajectoire une planification des
moyens financiers par ailleurs vous vous
avez évoqué la question du pacte et la
loi de l'orientation c'est dans le cadre
de ce pacte de cette loi d'orientation
que tout ça sera combiné pour mettre de
la cohérence et pour montrer la
cohérence de notre action et la première
la première ministre aura l'occasion de
le faire dans les prochaines semaines
voilà madame la sinénatrice ce que je
voulais vous dire Madame
Antoine merci Monsieur le Ministre
j'entends votre votre réponse l'ensemble
des mesures que vous évoquez ne répond
pas complètement à l'enjeu des prix du
partage et de la valeur ajoutée et nos
paysans souffrent dans nos
campagnes merci nous en avons terminé
avec les questions gouvernement je vous
rappelle que nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 29
novembre à 15h je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi
portant réparation des personnes
condamnées pour homosexualité entre 1942
et
1982 la séance est
suspendue